good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
if you dutifully watched joe biden
sputter through his announcement of the
administration's
2 trillion infrastructure plan yesterday
you may have been left with some
questions
first and most obviously is this really
about infrastructure bridges
roads airports things we could actually
use
or is it yet another weird climate
scheme slash power grab
race-based redistribution plan what
exactly is this
and by the way two trillion dollars
sounds like a lot for anything
won't that kind of spending cause
hyperinflation if you print money like
it's not worth anything doesn't the
value of that money decline
normal people may have had questions
like those but thankfully the new york
times was on the scene to quell all
doubt
the new york times approached joe
biden's plan with the enthusiasm of
izvestia applauding yet another record
soviet potato harvest
quote biden plan stresses jobs roads and
growth read one of the new york times's
four
separate front page headlines this
morning
two trillion for once in a generation
fix of infrastructure another headline
that's real ron claimed that tech
lobbyist turned white house chief of
staff was so grateful for the backup
from the times that he tweeted out the
front page this morning
america let's go win the future clayne
wrote
let's go win the future america what
does that future look like
well let's be clear from the outset that
this plan whatever its merits
will not make your commute easier only
about 5
of that 2 trillion will actually go to
roads and bridges
so 5 on infrastructure 95
on social engineering that's what joe
biden calls a once-in-a-lifetime
infrastructure bill and he's right about
part of it it is once in a lifetime if
this bill passes the next generation
will live in a very different country
now before we tell you what's in the
bill one word about who's going to pay
for it
in fact we only need one word and the
word is you taxes are going up
dramatically
and they didn't have to actually tax
revenues no longer fund
the ambitions of our political class
have you noticed the federal reserve
funds them when politicians want
something they just print the money
it's called modern monetary theory
they've been doing this for years and
it's accelerating
so there's no actual reason to raise
taxes anymore
for anything but joe biden wants to
raise taxes to punish you and he plans
to do that
the administration is calling for a tax
increase of about 3 trillion
over 10 years that includes taxes on
individual income and investments
as well as on corporations this would
make the first
major tax hike in 28 years but it's
actually a much
bigger tax hike than anything we saw
under the clinton administration in 1993
taxes amounted to only about half a
percent of gdp
this plan would come to roughly three
times that about
300 billion a year that's 1.3 percent of
gdp
so you'd have to go all the way back to
1968 to find a bigger tax
increase it's a big deal you have any
questions
no questions allowed joe biden doesn't
want to answer questions he doesn't have
to because it's an emergency
in emergencies you do what you're told
what i'm proposing is a one-time capital
investment of roughly two trillion
dollars in america's future
spread largely over eight years put
simply
these are investments we have to make we
can
afford to make them put another we can't
afford not to
all this can be yours america for just
two trillion dollars
we can't afford not to spend two
trillion dollars says joe biden like the
used car sales mini is at heart
biden knows he's not going to be paying
a dime people like joe biden
avoid taxes joe biden avoids taxes in
fact
in 2017 and 18 joe biden and his wife
dodged payroll taxes and more than 13
million dollars that they got through
speaking fees and book royalties how'd
they do that did you do that
you probably didn't they did the wall
street journal reported that the bidens
quote classified the income
as s corporation profits rather than
taxable wages
are you surprised oh come on
corporations are going to pay for it
yeah if only we'd support it if that
were the case
but they're not corporate interests put
joe biden in the white house
they designed his policy they sent off
on every part of it just as the credit
card companies in delaware once did
and so they'll be fine corporations
shelter most of their money from taxes
a lot of ways and when it costs they
pass the costs along to the workers in
the form of lower wages and to customers
in the form of higher prices
that's not a secret economists know that
and so does joe biden so none of this is
going to hurt amazon that's why amazon's
for it
but joe biden is interested in getting
into the details like the math
he'd like to know this bill is going to
turn america
into a scene from the jetsons imagine
what we can do
what's within our reach we modernize
those highways
you and your family can travel coast to
coast without a single
tank of gas on board a high-speed train
we can connect high-speed affordable
reliable internet wherever you live
imagine knowing that you are handing
your children and grandchildren
a country that will lead the world on
producing clean energy technology
and will need to address one of the
biggest threats of our time that's what
we'll do
flying cars teleport machines
sadly not but we are going to modernize
those highways
and honestly a lot of them could use it
but what does modernizing highways mean
exactly what are the details in that
well the washington post gave us some
idea
according to the paper an activist
called amy steli has been demanding the
removal not the building the removal of
a highway in new orleans that cuts
through her neighborhood
she thinks that highway called the
claiborne expressway
is bad it's an eyesore and it
contributes to pollution
in her neighborhood and for years she's
demanded local leaders get rid of it but
they've refused
people use it it's an important stretch
of road in new orleans
but now the white house and joe biden's
infrastructure plan
have decided that highway is an example
of quote
historic inequity and that can be solved
by billions in new spending in other
words
it's a racist highway so you've got to
pay to tear it down
amy stelli was enthused by this i'm
floored she said
i'm thrilled to hear president biden
call out the claiborne expressway
as a racist highway yeah and not just
racist
sexist and transphobic too that highway
is a jim crow dog whistle for white
supremacy not to mention q and on
insurrections
got to tear it down expect a lot more
highways to meet that face
fate people who believe highways or
racists are going to get tens of
billions of dollars as part of this plan
as long as they're what the biden
administration calls
underserved communities the entirety of
this infrastructure plan
looks more like a mash-up of
intersectional theory from wesley and in
some kind of south african style spoils
system
we saw a taste of that earlier this year
when joe biden sent billions of dollars
to african-american farmers in this
country purely because of how they look
now that's illegal it's immoral it's
completely divisive but it's just the
beginning
in his infrastructure bill joe biden
calls pretty
strongly for sending 25 billion to
historically black universities another
quote minority serving institutions for
research and development
now you may think it's a good idea you
should have to explain why
but it's not infrastructure he'd also
like to eliminate quote
exclusionary zoning and quote needless
barriers to producing affordable housing
so that means that your neighborhood may
have to make way for multi-family
dwellings
you don't want multi-family dwellings in
your neighborhood
it doesn't matter because it's equity
shut up racist and there's more where
that came from
joe biden would like to spend a hundred
billion dollars for workplace
development to quote reduce racial
inequities in job training and hiring
huh that doesn't sound like eliminating
racial discrimination and hiring
it sounds like mandating it and it is
but wait a second you may be wondering
what does hiring people with certain
skin colors have to do with
infrastructure sorry to keep bringing us
back to the point but the point was
supposed to be infrastructure
it's not really and democrats aren't
really pretending it is anymore
they're in charge and this is their
chance to take total control of the
economy
and they're going to use it we
understand to save our democracy and to
evolve into the multi-racial democracy
that we are we have to take a holistic
approach so we spoke about
infrastructure in alignment with a green
new deal
ending our dependence on fossil fuels
within the next 10 years
we spoke about education and fully
funding our public schools
and cancelling student debt we spoke
about repealing the hyde amendment a
federal jobs guarantee
we spoke about a variety of issues in
alignment with the progressive
priorities
that the people of this country are
demanding
so this is why you don't want the theory
people in charge of anything especially
the dumb
theory people like the one you just saw
sleazeball politicians of old would make
the case vote for me and i'll fix the
potholes
now they may have stolen some of the
money you sent them but in the end they
had to fix the potholes they promised
that they would
and your commute got a little better
these people are not interested in
fixing the potholes
no it's about saving our democracy and
evolving into a multi-racial democracy
as if we haven't already done that by
the way
it's also about something called the
green new deal that's what this is
and it's not simply one deranged theory
adult member of congress admitting it
according to the transportation
secretary pete buddha judge former mayor
of south
bend former road scholar and
mckinsey consultant we need this
infrastructure bill to end hurricanes
in the united states transportation is
the leading contributor to climate
change
contributing to a pattern of extreme
weather events which
takes a severe toll on our
infrastructure
every dollar we spend rebuilding from a
climate driven disaster
is a dollar we could have spent building
a more competitive
modern and resilient transportation
system that produces significantly lower
emissions
so according to climatologist pete judge
wait we thought he was a mckinsey consul
no no he's a climate expert
not even the climate experts understand
the climate that's how complex is but
people what a judge does
and he's telling you it's the roads that
are causing hurricanes we never had them
before roads
he's going to fix that and that explains
why there is 46 billion dollars in this
bill for the federal government to buy
electric vehicles now
fbi agents can arrest you for sedition
while driving teslas
but wait a second you ask aren't those
teslas powered by electricity made in
part by coal plants yeah whatever
shh insurrectionist another 2 trillion
goes
2 billion rather goes to tax credits for
quote clean energy generation and
storage
oh i wonder who owns those firms could
they be biden donors
think so there's also a plan for
building 500 000 electric vehicle
charges an allocation of 174 billion to
expand the market of electric vehicles
no one wants to buy them
government's going to make you want to
buy them and then 10 billion for
climate conservation corps to quote
boost climate resilience
are they going to buy umbrellas that
would be a useful form of climate
resilience but they're thinking bigger
than that this is about transforming our
democracy
you'll notice that none of this spending
goes to our oil workers just put out of
business when biden canceled the
keystone xl pipeline
they can learn to code so according to
people who are really running the
democratic party though none of this
goes far enough
it's just not enough 2 trillion is not
enough
we humiliate the keystone workers we're
spending 2 trillion dollars but we need
to go farther
according to sandy cortez pampered scion
of westchester
we need to spend a lot more money very
quickly or you're racist
i have real concerns that 2.2 trillion
isn't actually going to get us there
so we're going to have to make deeper
investments we are in a devastating
economic moment
millions of people in the united states
are unemployed we have
a truly crippled health care system
and a planetary crisis on our hands and
we're the wealthiest nation in the
history of the world so
we can do 10 trillion
oh another math lecture from sandy 10
trillion 10 trillion dollars okay
cindy cortez you've added a lot to our
country you built this country didn't
you
she doesn't care and by the way none of
them care about the consequences of this
what are the consequences of this
exactly what happens if all this money
gets into the system could it affect
your life could it affect
prices commodity prices take a look at a
chart
of commodity prices and that will give
you some sense you're looking at one
these are the increases over the past
year the government injected trillions
of dollars
into the economy and what happened the
cost
of almost every durable good the things
that you need to live went
way up the price of lumber we might need
that going forward jumped more than 250
crude oil went up 188 sugar 50
copper and tin up by more than 80
percent each
cattle meaning meat wheat meaning wheat
thins
and so on a lot more expensive to live
here that's fine if you're joe biden or
sandy cortez
not fine if you're you the cost to buy a
home jumped by 11
according to the un food price index the
cost of food has reached its highest
level
in seven years in other words just by
spending a lot of money they didn't make
the people in charge are making it much
harder for most americans to live here
that's the cost of inflation
it's a tax and it's insidious and it's
impossible to control once it starts
meanwhile the most powerful people in
the country have never been happier the
cost of apartments in san francisco has
gone way down
the dow jones up by 50 private equity is
booming crypto investors are seeing huge
returns
some of them have so much money they are
making up things to buy like what else
do you do with the money
they're investing in something called
non-fungible tokens
nfts which are literally useless digital
tokens
the nyan cat meme which you're seeing on
your screen just sold for 590
000 in nft format
now it's not the art that was sold it
was the useless digital token
this is the tulip craze if there ever
was one
and these are the people benefiting from
you another two trillion dollars in
spending and by the way those taxes
increases
will not offset all of this spending joe
biden plans to tax what economists call
savers which don't bounce around as much
in the economy taxing favors is not an
effective way to curb
inflation because the money isn't
affecting as many transactions
it's punitive but the party in charge
isn't cared about it doesn't care about
inflation
they don't care if it's harder for you
to get gasoline or buy dinner
they're just upset that you feel
entitled to drive your vehicle to work
on their roads
i do think that given the preference
i and probably many others would like to
see
the gasoline tax raised
as you know that has been talked about
for decades
and unfortunately americans have become
so accustomed to the low
gas prices and even though i was
challenging anybody if they go
leave wherever they are right now
looking at this at your show to go out
and ask 10 people
how much they pay in in the federal
gasoline taxes they can't tell you
they won't be able to tell you until a
number is put out there when somebody
says we're going to raise the taxes
in order to to pay our infrastructure
costs or the rebuilding by
infrastructure
and then all of a sudden somebody will
start waging a war
yeah so the real problem with america is
gas prices are too low
so people who don't live in cities
people who drive for a living just
aren't paying enough that's the problem
and those ungrateful americans don't
even know it
what's going on here trillions of
dollars
changing hands this is looting
just as their supporters in minneapolis
last summer the biden people are looting
the country they have done nothing to
build america not one thing susan rice
barack obama ron clean
the rest of these people making these
decisions have not created a single
thing
they are not creators they are takers
and they've gotten rich from doing it
how much does susan rice make in the
last four years how did you get that
money
they're just stripping the course corpse
and when it falls apart they'll be gone